[Musica]
ok nella a tutti i ragazzi mi aiuti a
questo video io sono sempre più contento
di far star all allora siamo su un
gelato devotion ok quindi il nome figo
speriamo lo sia anche il gioco questo
gioco l'hanno rimosso perché troppo
esagerato quindi ho detto a me lo
portiamo chissenefrega del fermi
difendete solo se ancora guardato la tv
si dibatte sta tornando a casa tardi
non faccio in tempo a leggere fa niente
date un horror io comunque quei giochi
thailandesi non ci vado proprio nozze
visto che l'ultimo che ho fatto è stato
3 doubt c'era un horror veramente
pesantissimo raga questo l'hanno rimosso
da steam
ve lo ripeto per l'ennesima non avete
idea di cosa voglia dire norma del
genere cioè su steam c'e di tutto c'è
anche outlast l'anno questo la per
averlo tolto cosa diavolo ci sta
succedendo qualcosa di strano tipo sta
andando in crisi epilettica ma non sto
capendo perché io sto facendo niente sta
facendo tutto lui mi scusi
ancora un piatto e possiamo mangiare si
però tesoro io sto venendo non so come
mai è talmente dalla fame e cioè fame
al pranzo un panino al volo ancora non
ci credo più dalla fame
che cosa è successo non capisco salve vi
posso alzare da suo divano è un gioco
dove fisso di televisori mi alzo dal
divano ok abbiamo già un plus rispetto
all'inizio che erano un po che non
incalzava un horror proprio di questo
genere c'è proprio tutto diroccato
schifoso cioè nel senso di schifoso di
ambientazione noi loro sembra fatto
veramente bene
sembra che stia ascoltando il gioco anzi
no posso uscire mamma mia che brutta
entrata se posso permettermi amore non è
un entrata c'è un'altra stanza qua c'è
perché ti hanno preso una casa e l'hanno
messa speculare c'è il riflesso allo
specchio mi scusi lei è in casa mia non
mi spunta come minimo snoop dogg
io lo so chi è che ti sulla porta si è
beccato un ombrello e voluta questa cosa
c'è un ombrello che volteggia c'era un
horror giapponese di pare fosse di po
coreano tipo la scarpetta rossa una roba
del genere porca [ __ ] porca via via
via via via piaciuti sia dietro c'è una
tizia dietro a 3 io questi giochi di mel
però non li posso fare quando è sera mi
scusi no e perché dai per cortecci il
bello che me ne sono accorto che c'era
una ditta potevo anche non accorgermene
però io che sono un posto ne sono
accorto ecco se vedete scarpette rosa
abbandonate per terra attacchi
soprattutto non toccate non giratevi
morite o troppo la chiave chiave della
casa hanno la scimmia 1980 apre
dimentare cioè incredibile e sta nella
vita questa è stata lo è stato l'oggetto
che utilizzato più in fretta della
storia dei videogiochi si è trovata la
chiave usata subito cosa la metti a fare
allora per non ammettere mi spiegate che
cosa c'è di così strani sto gioco da
sarà addirittura abbandonato su steam
no perché voglio veramente
io io adesso giocherò tutto il gameplay
tutto il gameplay cercando di capire
perché hanno bannato soggioga stime
primo paghino a ecco perché ho attaccato
la foto li fung al muro
mi piace perché è facile capire cosa
devi fare ai pochi oggetti ma c'è però
adesso e poi magari belle scoperte
anzi proporrei data la stanza figo però
io continua a non esserci nei riflessi
delle cose fa niente questo a picchiare
un cappotto vi solcato sotto e va bene
quindi vedi che posso mettere qua il
trofeo
no ho messo anche il trofeo sia arredato
salotto arrechiamo anche la cucina nella
cucina arredata quindi a posto tuo
arrivato tutto devo solo mettere niente
ok vado a sedermi dietro il divano se
possibile non sotto il divano sarebbe
anche più utile sotto l'iva no c'è un
divano dove posso strisciare no ok
madonna
c'è un ambientazione orribile si può
uscire
non c'è neanche la torcia c'è l'unico
gioco dove non sa che non ha la torcia e
questo è saltato il fusibile beh ottimo
ballerina dall sempre paura girarvi ci
stanno
ma che san valentino insomma un po in
anticipo cosa devo fare
spegni la la radio spegne stanley ah no
che pensa questo gioco quello del no sta
succedendo ora grazie
non capisco highlighter e l'accendino
adesso vedo no niente
adesso vedo tutto voi tutto a posto
1986 quindi stiamo tornando un po come
se fosse una specie di viaggio nel tempo
c'entriamo usciamo dalla casa ogni tot e
cambiano le cose
va bene c'è una c'è gente c'è ci sono
manichini vabbè è sempre comunque
qualcosa di meglio
1986 quindi già cambiato rispetto a
prima
certo che io ho sempre detto nella mia
vita come vitalità la mia ex era un po
un legno però voi non scherzate neanche
max secondo me possiamo continuare anche
a scherzare se volete cioè dipende da
quello che volete fare se io odio io me
la vivo tranquillo è per carità di dio
anzi fate fate quello che dovete fare
senza che nessuno vi disturbi anzi ci
mancherebbe io vado anzi c'è una porta
qua semi aperta che adesso è arredata ci
dà un'occhiata se non mi dispiace è nata
una bimba che prima non c'era una
piccola sedia perché sentono i rumori e
non mi piacciono stai ancora di to see
perfetto stata no perché qua
arriviamo a situazioni discutibili
permesso salve quindi posso prendere
grazie attualmente sulla sedia arco
demonio
l'avevo visto sto tizio prendo anche la
polaroid non la prendo la polaroid
fatevi le foto io non mi disturba tutto
a posto qua a sé girato anche il tizio
adesso mi guardano tutti mi sento
osservato facciamo che chiudo la porta
non si può chiudere la porta fa niente
posso mettere alla bambola senza che mi
uccidi a te
ok anzi arredato il punto della casa ok
no no no no devo mettere la ballerina
bella ballerina sul piano non fatemi
scherzi non fate miss che non posso
metterla qua devo mettere una devo
ammettere che ci sono un sacco di
oggetti che puoi trovare però fermi
dovete sta però belli siete sempre che
questo il bagno ho trovato lo spartito
io metto lo spartito però non mi dovete
toccare il ciapet ragazzi non mi toccate
il ciapi denuncio vi ammazzo visito le
braccia ok quest'anno frank io ma non
dovevate non dovevate addirittura per il
compleanno ma se ci piazza si questa
bellissima ballerina sulla torta ma cosa
c'è dai non una ma due ballerine c'è
meraviglioso la torta del secolo
quindi gioco finito basta basta horror
basta horror gioco finito questa è la
finale finale caput finito gioco finito
titoli di coda
volevo essere famosa come uno su come
mamma io no non te lo consiglio poi un
casino se vai in duomo fare i self in
bordello non puoi girare tranquillo
quindi beh però burqa [ __ ] che è
successo no no non c'è nessuno occupato
torrini torni un altro giorno cosa
faccio la vacca perché poi deve esserci
proprio in casa andare a vedere chi è
ho capito entry prego e chi era anno
della tigre ok fin qua ci siamo chi che
dietro non compare il satana siamo a
posto
apri la porta a prima porta aprì la
porta 1985 andiamo indietro nel tempo
eravamo all 86
porca vacca io volevo andare sempre più
avanti 1985 dichiara meglio rimane
indietro
quindi non si capisce che c'è scritto ma
forse è meglio a lavati le mani prima di
entrare ok andiamo a farci le mani non
c'è motivo ma va bene lavandino perché
poi tra l'altro io lo farei fare a tutte
le boe ha corso sono pulito posso
entrare forse è meglio se non te le navi
più io eviterei di lavarle nel lavandino
però fai quello che vuoi
fai quello che vuoi tanto le mani su due
fatto non c'è il 6 nel riflesso
fortunatamente ok pulito bene mi sono
lavato le mani posso entrare ma c'è
bisogno di ponente ring sono lavato le
mani magari perché c'era qualcuno di
malato qui c'è la bambola c'è la bambola
rappresentava dilata la bambina che gli
ho tolti sei a posto quindi
nel 1985
ho trovato le a ok fronte delle cose a
raggi ics ci sono dei manichini non
persone quindi non è cruento per questo
a quanto pare a devo muoverli devo farla
io va bene non sono mai stato bravo con
i puzzle però vabbè change direction ad
evo devo proprio proiettarlo da qualche
parte li fenomeno quindi sulla bambino
che la bambina sala dei problemi ho
capito non continuiamo capito la bambina
aveva problemi pronto vodafone pronto ce
l'hai già la fibra si gioca un giga vita
ho sentito lob riguardato la situazione
non preoccuparti dia inizio al piano di
sopra e incontriamo e piani sopra c'è un
piano di sopra
ma va non esiste un piano di sopra qua
lo conosco come in di come le mie tasche
sta a casa non c'è un piano di sopra ha
forse dal corridoio c'è un buddha no non
è wood scherzavo
l'ho visto malissimo
ma che ca o si sta allagando tutto c'è
un problema mi scusi aiuto aprite arco
demonio porco aprite la ma si sfonda il
vetro la pressione dell'acqua ma si
sfonda si sfonda il vetro tranquilli si
sfonda il vetro si sfonderà io conosco
la fisica non so dove sia ma sono
contento che non ci sia eccoci bel bagno
pomeriggio distende i nervi bijoux tutto
a posto tranquillo tanto ho visto di
peggio negli horror ti sei svegliato da
bambina
porca vacca la seco la seguo stato
soprattutto sporco di sangue ma fa
niente ma torna che schifo che scelta di
design e avere una vasca nel mezzo del
salotto è allora collezioni frammenti
del passato per attraversare il flawless
non mi ricordo voglia dire presente
amici si sono aperte 26 porte a credo
che questa sia più o meno il centro per
poi continuare ho capito quindi devo
continuare dove c'è la striscia rosa
però prima di continuare devo
attraversare ogni singolo punto
ok ok ragazzi questo era il primo
episodio di devolution che è un horror
bellissimo io spero che vi sia piaciuto
sia già della campanella prima ragionati
simonino tra pochissimi giorni e sui
continui noi ci vediamo come sempre a
questo video the da ragazzi
[Musica]